comment vous me trouvez ma démo zulia
très rythmique nico vous n'avez pas vu
mon ami françois enfin casimir et c'est
très bien c'est moi françois voulait
bien enlevé vous prenez monsieur pique
nique aux la wii c'est toi françois
excuse moi même si on ne sait jamais si
c'est quoi monsieur pique nique ont
enfin casimir tu sais très bien que
chaque fois que le clown pique nique au
hellas et ses lettres aux soins qui est
en dessous mais très chers amis bonjour
à excusez moi monsieur je croyais trouvé
mon ami françois geste mais les clones
dit nick ont alors oui françois il était
là il ya une minute que casimir je sais
moi françois a pour sûr je vous aurais
jamais reconnu 2 années mon avis pour
mme avait mystifié déguisés comme ça pas
vrai ça j'avoue que me déguiser en clown
pique nique aux c'est une de mes
distraction préférée par sa dalle très
intéressant moi aussi j'adore me
déguiser mais j'ai eu une idée si nous
formions un petit cirque tout sens aux
radiations
[Musique]
aujourd'hui les clowns pique nique au
tout petit cirque et magie quitter l'île
aux enfants
il est très heureux de vous présenter la
troupe qu'il a me semble un peu près et
tout d'abord sont plus petites cuillères
de la maladie sont petites et quyen très
gracieuse que chez dénommé c'est
mademoiselle souligna qu'il est très
très très très soul et une révérence
s'il vous plaît
ou le baiser à l'assistance merci
mademoiselle sourire ah oui c'est mon
cheval fougueux qui s'avance qui
s'appelait didier hunan
les blocs mais selon lui il est très
gentil
si les enfants iv louis denis abrogé il
mangera avec ont été cannes s du sexe
amandine est autrement ou une blouse
tout jeune il par le consuel mêmes ténor
et louis que vous attendez tous
faisaient attention à ces menaces
gd l'éducation store qui venait des
plaines où est elle
elle ajouté s'il vous plaît s'il vous
plaît aussi claqué votre fouet non non
le grand casillas kopnord ne fait pas
cas qu'ils sont frais pour ne pas faire
peur aux enfants
mais il sait très bien faire claquer sa
langue est coupée voilà je la veux bien
vous à vos aînés outillage et on parlait
limité place au spectacle traces au silk
en place pour le premier numéro
mademoiselle julie à elle va danser pour
vous s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ok
[Musique]
non mademoiselle julie à la baignade
battez vous elle souligna et courriels
avec son cheval kiruna had me doucet lui
plaît bien
[Musique]
allez bisous parfait mais d'où vient de
sa lubie d'où la plus lisse est alors
n'attendez du caoutchouc
une autre encore
salut vous l'appelez y serait allé vers
un drame un bisous à toi mille visiteurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bravo mais dur et cette fois à 12h à
doumy nous saluent vous
l'applaudissement
[Applaudissements]
maintenant casimir score pas à compenser
me do et parents un gloubi boulga mais
auparavant il va faire partout vos
pistes et tu fais je joue plus
maintenant anomalies dont l'année de
cheveux steevy tiens à m'en fous les
spectacles ils comptent ni leur avec les
pneus grade et tous le plus fort quasi
dix gros travaux fait entrer les forces
hors des casinos scott oke qui me font
très peu ce l'effort attention kazimierz
cov ouvre la cage up sont mêmes ignorent
quasi nestor vous présente ces puces
savantes
[Musique]
on lui aurait bien mais moi l attention
on est en dessous de ré au pouce en tout
temps sans doute vous étiez en retard
mademoiselle et livia très bien bon
numéro de balançoire mademoiselle
charlène et mademoiselle annabelle très
bien voilà ça c'est du beau travail
avait mordu mademoiselle lydia bravo
très bien maintenant triple saut
périlleux en arrière alors la bazoge
accru nos données par des coups de
pierres vos camarades
voilà très bien son job pour l'ensemble
voilà très bien même moi celle jj vous
avez encore grossi attention
mademoiselle annabelle dans son numéro
en europe le voltigeur
très bien très bien
voilà pourquoi cette germaine la
balançoire et on termine par un triple
saut périlleux tout ensemble
ah bon on va pas les droits de l'attrapé
attendez je crois que je le mets à
parler
merci-facteur voilà vous voilà juin
moi ce que j'aime dans le métier de
dompteur c'est le danger les dangers
connus score vive les sikhs vivent les
pétitions que magic telli nos emplois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]